talk a little bit about working with the
legacy cast um were you guys pinching
yourself to have the ogs back with you
you ready
for this
never oh yeah yeah i think you know the
movie wouldn't have worked if we didn't
have them like they're
uh
you know the such an iconic part of it
and they were so kind and so nice and
um
david was like especially welcoming and
stayed in the same hotel that we were
staying at and
you know let us borrow his red tricycle
and
he you know taught us all to paint in
the style of bob ross and so i think
immediately we all sort of became like
this little family it was
yeah
they were so lovely i remember we had
this dinner our first big dinner
together at our favorite thai place over
there in north carolina and it was kind
of an emotional moment because they were
talking about you know how this really
feels
it feels so much like
you know the
when they were shooting like the
original you know like the new cast
together and that was that was really
heartwarming and it felt
amazing to be welcomed by them and like
feel so included and and you know um
and be a part of something that we had
so much respect for and we're such big
fans of um
with
incredibly talented people that we
looked up to yeah
yeah hey jenna i want to ask you
something specific about this opening
scene right it's like such an honor to
be in the opening scene did you feel any
pressure at all doing that opening scene
which you crushed by the way was so good
but did you feel any like living up to
drew barrymore pressure
this isn't funny amber when do you like
to play a game tara
of course well the thing about it is
the drew barrymore casey beckerstein is
one of my favorite scenes of all time
across the board in cinema
[Applause]
also it could not have been done more
perfectly so it's hard because i know
that
all the screen film scenes have been
sort of a
reiteration or kind of a play on that
scene so it was kind of um wanting to
make this one somewhat different somehow
but also not seem like i was trying to
rip anybody off i i could never do that
i could i wanted to make my own but i
also wanted to um
make sure that the the acknowledgement
and respect for drew and west and kevin
was was there and done and i know that
people are very critical because that
sets such a standard it being the first
scene of the franchise and it being so
iconic that um it's something that i
think the scream community critiques a
lot and it's very um
hardcore about i i just really didn't
want to let anyone down
listen i am the scream community i was
born in the 80s that came up on these
you ain't letting nobody down you guys
rock this thing and you bring your whole
new flavor the new school the new school
cast of all you guys is what makes this
movie shine
[Applause]
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers we love our
legacies don't get me wrong but you can
easily mess up casting and they nailed
it with you guys i'm telling you you
guys were perfect in this thing
um tell me a little bit about shooting
at stu's house i mean as a fan
it was amazing to watch and see all
these new people and these new
circumstances taking place what was that
like for you let's start on the top with
sonia it was pretty crazy because we
actually remember one day i think it was
on halloween night we
were in the studio where the house was
and we watched the original like the
first film and
on a screen that was right next to the
house and we saw like the original house
the movie right next to the house that
we were shooting it and that was
mind-blowing um
and they did an incredible job at um at
creating the house it's going to look
super cool in the film i think it's the
same dimensions and everything too they
went out and they measured the actual
home because we couldn't shoot
you know film was shot at and um yeah we
all got to visit that set and it was
really exciting to see and and be around
and know that that's what it was really
like hey jenna you that opening scene i
i don't want to let this go it was
pretty
violent i don't want to give anything
away it was like seemed like there were
some stunts involved did you get injured
at all i mean the way the scene plays i
felt like i was bruised after watching
it how was it for you
yeah i
i mean there's videos on my phone i had
some of the biggest bruises of my life i
had this bruise on my hip that kind of
it looked like a tennis ball from the
side because it was swollen um i had
matching bruises on each of my elbow
bones you know the ones that protrude
right there
i had a couple on the side of my thigh
some on my knees uh but that's what i
like getting bruised up when you do
stunts like that because you know you
really gave it your your all in any
reaction you have if you do end up
hurting yourself it's authentic and real
and
yeah this that stuff is fun mickey talk
to me about uh the the i want to talk
about the bob ross thing we mentioned in
the beginning so so david gave you guys
bob ross painting lessons how does that
happen and then what is that experience
like
yeah it was so sweet and so unexpected
because i've i had no idea that you
could become a certified bob ross
painting instructor i didn't know that
ken
yeah yeah you go and take a course for
three weeks in new smita beach florida
you can become a
instructor as well so yeah i uh bought a
bunch of the kits and then they invited
everyone down there's this little room
that we'd all meet in and then i set
them all up and just taught him how to
fill out a paint and it was a it was a
really fun bonding experience it
happened right at the beginning it was
kind of like
getting to know each other he was super
kind and generous he went out and bought
these painting kits for us and
like we all lined them up in this circle
and he just taught us how to paint this
beautiful landscape and
yeah it was so sweet and so kind and
such a great bonding experience you guys
really all seemed like a family on this
set i know with covet and the protocols
everybody's in a bubble but it's those
moments that that that show up on
screens that you guys are connected in
all these scenes and it probably started
at the bob ross painting lesson which is
amazing
now you guys pay homage to wes craven
kind of throughout this movie a couple
of times how important was that for all
of you guys to be involved and and
kind of give a shout out and a nod to
the man the myth the legend i think my
biggest thing
going into this movie was i was you know
i was already a fan of um of matt and
tyler but i really loved and appreciated
how much
emphasis they put on
um honoring wes and that this film was
for wes and um and they were such huge
fans of wes and of the franchise and of
the film that it really felt
like
we're
you know
we're honoring him and it's a love
letter to to the genre and to him and
and to scream and
so that i had
it felt like
okay
i feel like he would be proud of this
and
and i feel like
we're all very proud of this film
i mean wes craven being being the horror
icon he is and leaving such an impact on
the genre and
film in general i think um
to be a part of something like this
um and especially without him for the
first time
is really nerve-wracking but
also really exciting
um
just because um
knowing that we all had so much respect
for the work that he had done and
everybody was going in with the same
um effort or everyone wanting to put
their best foot forward and make someone
proud i think that it really gave us
kind of the best possible outcome of the
film or you know just knowing that
everyone tried and
love was there and i think that that
really
affects the atmosphere on a set and
really makes or break a film